i have a problem
i have a problem named listen to
distractible
you may notice that there's something
that wasn't what i said in there because
i'm not going to say their name
because i only want to promote things
that are worth promoting
link in the description for distract
people there is a
brand that has disrespected me after
everything that i've done for said brand
after everything that i've given
of my time of space on my channel
i gave my heart to them or i tried to
anyway they never reciprocated
you know they say sour than sweet but
it's really just sour all the way down
but it's not because their product isn't
even that sour
but then they decided to give their
affections to someone known as tim the
tatman
i get it tim's great
great so you live your life and i'm
gonna live
my life with better superior sour
candies that are more sour destructive
to the teeth
and destructive to i don't know
the arteries something like that stomach
lining you know when i want
sour i want to be kicked in the teeth
with the sour
and my teeth are brittle because of the
sour so they will be kicked right out of
my mouth
when i want sour i don't know why i did
that when i want
sour i want to hurt as is evident by my
shockingly sour challenge that i did
with some friends of mine
whereby my tongue basically melted off
by the end of it if you haven't seen
that video
don't it's rather painful to watch
i would like to kick this video off with
one of my favorite sour candies
of all it's actually kind of hard to buy
by itself
so i have to buy this bag which is three
different gums
the other gums i don't really care about
i literally buy this bag because
in the trifecta of gum it's got assorted
gumball
it's got double bubble of various stupid
flavors
and then it's got the real thing which
is crybaby extra sour bubblegum
[Applause]
i thought it was pre-sliced
in this is a gun called crybaby
this might be one of my favorite sour
candies of all because it's actually
sour
and then it's sweet because it's gum
oh my god
there's so few in the bag
what alexander just replace it with
various other distractible promos if
it's too gross
distractible listen to distractible we
have a podcast with bob wade and i
called distractible i'm not even near
your mouth and it's just
it's awful what are you saying about my
mouth
anyway damn good actually sour
and i don't know what it is about sour i
love sour stuff
maybe it's because german and korean not
koreans really have
sour foods either way i like sour i'm
just
a freak so um we're gonna keep this
brief we're gonna keep this moving
because what i have here is an assembly
of the best sour candies
on the market and with no exceptions
these are only the best everything else
you can assume is crap
and you shouldn't buy
i didn't get warheads i forgot
except for warheads anyway my second
there's many second favorites that i
have sour skittles
is such a beautiful example of how to
destroy your mouth
i don't know what they make these
crystals out of but they sharpen them
before they get out of the factory
anyone who's had one bag this size of
sour skittles
has started bleeding it's just how it is
but they're good they're good because
it's like salt in the wound when you get
those sour crystals
and you got the cuts in your mouth and
it hurts real good not a masochist and
it makes the flavor even better because
then it directly touches the nerves
and i think that's what associates the
sour right to the brain
you know how you if you imagine like
right now if i'm saying
imagine what sour candy tastes like or
what sour tastes like
you can almost feel it in your mouth
right now right
you feeling it i hate that feeling i
know but why is that a psychosomatic
thing where you can feel that
you can taste sour at any time because
you crave it it is a weird coincidence
probably unrelated that during my time
in the european leg of the your welcome
tour that i went on
i just so happened to get sick after
eating an entire industrial sized bag
of sour skittles which tore up my mouth
and maybe left me vulnerable to
bacteria i was on an airplane as well
yeah i ate this on an airplane this was
my choice of
airplane food i do not make good choices
but then again neither does it listen to
distractible distractible why don't you
live with your regret
forever you will never have this
you will never have this you won't have
this
ever unless
never how much did you pick tim anyway
sour skittles
[Music]
central to that it's not quite the same
kind of punch
that the uh the gumballs have because
these are just like
pure sour and what sour skittles offer
is
one if you like do more than once and
kind of like roll them around in your
mouth to like really melt down the
crystals and you melt down the shell
it's just a skittle down below that's
coated in sour powder so it's a very
nice sour that then melts away and
becomes
very sweet like a very satisfying
sweetness it's the best example of that
kind of mechanism of like good sour
coating
sweet center that i think you could ever
ask for
i don't even imagine there's anything
else that kind of captures that kind of
idea
i'm not gonna have teeth when i'm older
i've accepted this reality
i like sour more than i like my teeth i
go through
perpetual cycles of eroding and
restoring and eventually i will lose
that battle
and then i'll get dentures and then i'll
be able to keep eating
maybe i should pull them now i'd be able
to eat more sour
didn't you look that up like if you
brush your teeth right after eating sour
candy it's bad for you yeah because it
just grinds the acid in what you need to
do is wash your mouth out with like milk
or something or something to neutralize
the acids and then you can brush your
teeth
or use a restorative mouthwash
follow me for more tips and tricks about
how to eat more sour candy i'll give you
all the business
no one gives me any business
[Music]
am i not brand friendly no it's the
companies that are wrong
it's mr distracted that's wrong screw
you and screw everything you
love and screw your kids this listen to
listen to distractible oh lyxian is
replacing what i'm saying it just sounds
like i said greek
hey kids are great
distractible suck
maybe mike and i i've always thought
mike was better than ike
i don't want to put the brothers at odds
with each other but everyone knows mike
ike is just three quarters of mike
it's not really a competition it's
always one brother that's better
i thought it was going to be a plastic
bag down there
turns out it's just a box of candy i
would like someone to point out the
difference between these and jelly beans
scientifically speaking
[Music]
anyone know madness combat
combat madness madness combat some
people in the comments will know exactly
what i'm talking about others will not
and will live in confusion for a long
time
madness combat doesn't that look like
one of the little dudes
and that's at the right angle i feel
like
kind of looks like an among us guys
is that a normal thing to say it's so
freaking normy
oh
delicious don't get sour down your
windpipe
it's no good for anybody i'm not crying
this particular betrayal is not
emotional
i'm actually pretty detached from this
one
because it's actually hurts to lose the
one that i'm
not referring to or whatever brand that
maybe this video is about
very replaceable but also don't get this
down your windpipe that's not going to
be good for anybody but
very tasty i will admit it's sweet on
the outside sour on the inside which i
think is a new twist on things maybe
even the better way to do things
mike call me ike
i'll call you
[Applause]
i've had these before right i must have
at some point in my life had these
like as opposed to the straws they had
the straw too i just thought the bites
were a little more
right the straws that's what it is the
name sounded familiar but i couldn't
remember where it was
yeah shortened straws
these aren't sour at all i've always had
a problem with these
i know you just followed me on twitter
and i appreciate that
but i have very high standards and this
is nowhere near sour enough
because if you have sour in your name
and your product isn't even sour
then it's kind of just a disappointment
from the get-go it's almost false
advertising
now this also applies to distractible
because
they say sour in the name really they're
not that sour
in fact i don't think they're sour at
all i'm never gonna eat
whatever that is again um but it's not
that sour
and the problem is with with distracted
sour punch
bites that doesn't taste like good once
you get down to it
maybe that's just me maybe i'm a freak
the answer is yes but
personal preference not my favorite and
i can't tell the difference between the
different colors
but here's one that does have a lot of
flavor
airheads is this a situation where all
these are owned by the same umbrella
corporation and every corporation is
just giving you an illusion of choice
and nothing actually is different
and only about four mega corporations
own every single brand that exists in
the us
yeah what's the brand on the back of
their heads it goes on the backers a
little older
perfetti van mel concord convections
division of tootsie roll there you go
but these are very very good these might
be
third place i think
why make a tear if it doesn't tear
there's been a lot of opportunity to
improve bag design
i mean we get the plastics are bad for
the entire world and we should move away
from them as soon as possible
but if you're gonna have a plastic and
not have the right tear position for it
to tear open
99 six sigma percent of the time
why even do it why not make it a little
lower why not put a guideline a
perforation on it
i think i see another terror on the
other side i'm going to be able to
salvage this
there we go
oh these aren't the filled ones
there's some that have a filling you
know that way i could experience the
sour on the outside sweet on the inside
thing but these are good anyway
it's better with the filling not that
shower either
sour falls you didn't tell me to get
tired
i'm sorry it's okay they're good but
they're not
sourfuls and they're not that sour see
this is really the problem here is
not all these punch me in the
punch me in the dick with sourness i
don't
want to be in i don't want my sour
eating experience to be pleasurable in
any way
only pain i've never had this before
haribo i like haribo they also make
gummy bears
a serving is a little handful in
servings
means your hand is full you can't have a
little hand
for a little handful a little hand full
like a child's hand but i'm a man
i need a man-sized hand full
and i'm gonna get a man-sized handful
anyway whatever hair bow
i like haribo
doesn't taste too bad i actually like
the flavor i had to work through it a
little bit to get to the point
very very chewy but in a lot of ways
that's good because it makes it last
longer
there's so many candies that i'll just
chomp twice and then it'll be gone down
like gulp
but this one in particular actually has
some good flavor once you get down to it
i don't typically like this type of
gummy thing i'm not a gummy guy like
gummy bears but not that often
i'm more of like a pure fake sugar kind
of guy or dextrose which is
sugar but you know it's not naturally
occurring
but it was good not sour not shower at
all actually
like i'm i don't get why because it says
airheads extreme when you say extreme
like there's really got to be some
extreme to it
also shock tarts we didn't get damn it's
okay
shock tarts shock tarts
i love shock tarts lexing don't even
bother tracking it i'm just gonna try to
keep my hands very still
shock tarts right i love shock tarts and
i call them shock tarts even if they're
called sweet tart shuckers
which is a nonsense name why didn't you
just leave them as shock tarts because
that's what they were
i remember the willy wonka commercial
where he put a shock dart in his mouth
and his whole hair went electricity
maybe you didn't get the licensing for
that
maybe shock tarts was a competing brand
that you didn't get the uh
authority to say but shock tarts was a
better name and i'm always going to call
a shark tart still the day i die
now those are sour those are very very
sour all the way through which is
delicious
and what it should be
wow what a shock anyway
again one thing that says sour not sour
however these are delicious i think if
you find someone that doesn't like sour
worms
because i think it's so integral to like
childhood
you know biting it off right color line
or something like that
it's not terribly sour but it is very
good and satisfying because it's like
you're eating bugs
i don't like that
warheads so warheads are kind of like
hit or miss for me
because they claim to be an extremely
sour candy but the problem is i can't
pound them down
and in fact i've done this before in a
video i
i don't dislike them but i don't like
the flavor of them the actual candy
itself isn't that enjoyable
it's kind of like they've got this
powder coating on the outside which
admittedly is very sour and i do enjoy
the punch
but that's the only part of the candy
that i really enjoy the rest of it is an
un-sour candy
which is fine but i'm not really a hard
candy kind of guy
i want to chomp my way through this
you're going to tear apart maybe the
inside of my mouth and my tongue but my
teeth are going to be left intact
and that's just not okay unless you make
other types of candies that are just
sour and i want to know about it and if
you want to do a sponsorship i'm totally
open to it and then i'll change all
these words and say
beautiful things about you and everyone
you love
so that leaves just about everything
i've scraped the bottom of the barrel
i've tried everything
um man i guess i'll just have to open it
up for something that's like
not my favorite sour thing but i can't
think of anything else worth mentioning
which is why i'd like to introduce my
next contestant
flintstones sour gummies i did not know
this was a thing until amy brought it
home
i love the idea of this because if me as
a kid
i don't like the idea of this because me
and the kid knew about this i would have
overdosed on vitamins which is
apparently a thing that you can do so
watch out you can't just pound these and
expect the flu to go away
smell this does it smell like vitamins
i can't believe flintstone vitamins are
still a thing because flintstones is
like an
ip i don't know if it actually is like
still pervasive
in the common ethos of people's speaking
elixir make all that make sense
two two gummies for four years and older
one gummy for two and three years how
young are you supposed to eat these
i'm not joking started bad got better
now bad again what the hell
not sour why do people keep calling
things sour and it's
not sour if you want something to have
sour in the name you gotta make it sour
there's only one way to it you make a
sour thing you make it
sour that's the deal i don't buy
anything sour because i want a nice
experience
i want to hurt i want to bleed i want to
suffer
sour means suffering rearrange the
letters of sour you could suffer
i guess it makes sense
distractible want me to suffer but
you can't hurt me anymore i've moved
past you
i've moved on
oh also i didn't get it but
if you guys want a little industry
secret uh there's a gourmet gumball
that you can get it's available on
amazon but it's probably they probably
have their own website once i find it
i'm going to tell lixian about it i'm
going to put it up here
but there's a gourmet gumball that you
can get that's kind of like these and
you can buy
[Music]
this it's kind of like crybabies but in
fact they're a little bit better because
in the center of the gumballs of cry
like crab baby it's like sour on the
outside and it's gum but in the center
in the center is a pure deposit
of just sour crystal it is amazing
because you can either melt through it
but as soon as you bite into it that
sour crystal mixes
with the gum itself and it makes the
whole gum sour without being a
sour just basically gum which doesn't
really work as well
you know what i mean it is beautiful
when i find it the link will be in the
description
i think it might be a smaller shop so
you might sell them out maybe that'd be
a good thing
i'm not even going to seek a sponsorship
about them they are just the best sour
candy that i've had
in a long long time these however are
close seconds so whoever the hell makes
crybaby tootsie mr titsy
miss tootsie mrs tootsie
why don't you give me a call hey
we could be friends we could be very
good friends
unlike some people who is not my friend
anymore never was actually now that i
think about it
have insulted their stuff a lot but
that's only because
i didn't like it
i have a question actually with all of
these why is green the designated color
for sour candy
like did skittles establish that
i don't know but the sour apple
sour apple is green
good answer for more sour related facts
and factoids hey
follow me on youtube.com markiplier
you can find me every monday on uh
spotify or apple podcast on my podcast
distractible
this youtube thing's just a little hobby
for me my main stay is over on distract
and as far as it goes for mr
distractible
i'm sorry you missed your chance